[Musique]
bienvenue à dulut sur le bord du
gigantesque lac Supérieur Jonathan
Jenkins a quitté sa Californie pour
venir s'établir ici loin des palmiers
mais près de l'eau
cela fait maintenant quelques années
qu'il a recommencé sa vie dans la petite
ville du Minnesota avec sa famille
il en a eu assez des désastre
californiens
il fait partie de ces réfugiés
climatiques qui ont quitté leur état de
plus en plus en proie aux aléas du
climat Jerry Arend a fait le choix de
quitter la région de Sonoma l'été
dernier
qu'ils viennent de Californie du
Colorado ou d'autres États victimes des
changements climatiques il serait
quelques centaines à avoir déménagé à du
luth lors des dernières années
c'est intéressé à ce phénomène des
réfugiés climatiques qui a certains
avantages
sur cette migration le salon de coiffure
de Adeline Wright est une bonne façon de
prendre le pouls de cette tendance
croissante 10% de sa clientèle vient
maintenant d'ailleurs et elle voit cela
d'un très bon œil pour dulutin
mais comment ces réfugiés particuliers
sont-ils perçus par les gens d'ici
représentant de sa ville et content de
cette afflux mais il n'en faudrait pas
trop
il préfère que sa ville reste un petit
secret bien gardé n'empêche c'est arrivé
un impact social plutôt indésirable
pour s'en rendre compte il suffit de se
pencher sur le marché immobilier local
n'a pour l'instant qu'une une maison à
vendre dans son portefeuille les
réfugiés climatiques y sont pour quelque
chose
un an moves
de quoi mettre la pression à la hausse
sur les prix ce qui frustre aussi les
résidents locaux
mais c'est réfugiés climatiques
peuvent-ils échapper à ce qu'ils ont fui
à l'origine
leur Charleux a déménagé de la France
ici il y a une douzaine d'années cette
professeur de géographie a constaté que
les changements climatiques se font
ressentir ici d'une autre façon on a des
longues périodes de sécheresse ou de
longues périodes très humide au
contraire qui qui
qui donne lieu à des inondations la
promenade le long du lac a été refaite
d'une manière beaucoup plus solide ces
dernières années avec beaucoup de
drogues etc pour que lors de ces grosses
tempêtes le tout ne soit pas érodé même
si on est encore loin des désastres
californiens ou autres on suit quand
même de près ces impacts sur les
infrastructures locales face à cette
afflux de nouveaux résidents
en attendant c'est adaptation phénomène
des réfugiés climatiques qui touchent
d'autres villes du Midwest comme Buffalo
dans l'État de New York et Détroit au
Michigan les Californiens comme Jerry
continue de s'adapter à leur nouvelle
habitat
même si pour une autre fois Jonathan
jankins ne fera pas de surf aujourd'hui
sur le lac Supérieur faute devant et
donc de vagues il n'a pas l'intention de
plier bagages de sitôt
déjà bien appliqué dans la vie
communautaire et celle des gens
d'affaires il veut continuer de
participer à l'essor de duluxe sa
nouvelle ville qui sait peut-être il y
aura-t-il un jour un maire californien
au Minnesota